اذا بتوقيع اوروبي هذه المره الحرس الثوري
الايراني على بعد نصف خطوه من ان يصنف
تنظيما ارهابيا بعد مصادقه البرلمان
الاوروبي على مشروع القرار بانتظار
التصويت لاحقا ليس هذا فحست اذ ان القرار
الاوروبي دعا علانيه الى ادراج راس النظام
في ايران المتمثل ابراهيم رئيسي والمرشد
الاعلى علي الخامنئي في قائمه العقوبات
وكما كان متوقعا قرار دفع بطهران الى
الجنون وبالتالي توعدت بان هذه الخطوه
ستؤثر على الامن والاستقرار الاقليمي
والسلام العالم المهدده البرلمان الاوروبي
من عواقبه وخيمه وزير الخارجيه الايراني
دانا بشده القرار وحذر من ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيطلق النار على قدميه بادراج
الحرس الثوري على قوائم المنظمات
الارهابيه وعلى واقع هذه التحذيرات حضر
خبراء بشان الايراني من ان الرد الايراني
على تصنيف دراسه ثوري في قوائم الارهاب
الاوروبيه سيكون عبر تحريك من الشياكه في
كل من العراق وسوريا ولبنان ومحاوله ضرب
المصالح الغربيه هناك هناك مشروع قرار فرض
عقوبات على الحرس الثوري الايرانيه يشمل
وضع كل المؤسسات التابعه لهم مثل قوات
البسيج وفيلق القدس على قائمه المنظمات
الارهابيه
طبعا القمع الحاد للمتظاهرين في ايران
وتنفيذ العديد من عمليات الاعدام بين
المحتاجين ساهم ايضا برفع صوت البرلمان
الاوروبي للمطالبه بادراج الحرس الثوري في
قائمه الارهاب الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]